so the daily White House coronavirus
press briefings have really been the
stuff of Horrors in a number of ways we
see lies endless lies from Trump we see
delusions from his task force we see the
bullying of the doctors on the task
force into having to be really careful
and sort of walk on eggshells and be
very careful in how they couch what
happened and what needs to happen for
fear of angering Donald Trump we see
Trump never answering the questions of
reporters we're really seeing it all but
yesterday was a true authoritarian
nightmare with Donald Trump furiously
yelling at the room calling most of the
reporters in the room fakes which we'll
get to and there is so much here but it
is all founded in Donald Trump's
incipient narcissistic authoritarianism
and I'm not gonna go in chronological
order here but I'm gonna go sort of in
levels of authoritarian the fight is now
developing over whose authority is it to
reopen the country which is really about
reopening individual states not every
state closed at the same time not every
state fully closed and these were
decisions made by governors of different
sort of levels of common sense and
rationality Donald Trump is claiming
more and more that it is his absolute
authority to open up the country now
funny number one that he says this
because he never closed the country he
much later than many states had already
done it gave guidelines to states that
they should follow but more importantly
it's not funny at all it's actually
scary because Donald Trump has become
downright dictatorial and that's the
right word in his pronouncements that it
is up to him and him alone
and if a governor doesn't want to open
up a state Trump has the sole authority
absolute sole authority as president to
force them to do it here is Trump
escalating in his authoritarianism and
delusions of dictatorship what you're
trying no not at all let me just a very
simple I'm gonna put it very simply the
President of the United States has the
authority to do what the president has
the authority to do which is very
powerful the President of the United
States calls the shots if we
here for the States you would have had a
problem in this country like you've
never seen before we were here to back
them up and we back it we've more than
back them up we did a job that nobody
ever thought was possible it's a
decision for the President of the United
States now with that being said we're
gonna work with the states because it's
very important you have local
governments there pinpoint it it's
really you talk about it's a like a
microchip they're pinpointed we have
local government that hopefully will do
a good job and if they don't do a good
job I'd step in so fast but no they
can't do anything without the approval
of the president they know this runs
directly counter to the Constitution the
law states rights all of the things that
the people supposedly on Trump's side
have been fighting for for hundreds of
years I mean certainly decades in the
modern era of republicanism
here's another specific question from a
reporter and Trump is just not backing
down he wants to be the authoritarian
but he also wants to avoid any
responsibility when things go wrong
nothing is his responsibility but
everything is his sole absolute
authority more and more sounding like
Kim il-sung and Kim jong-il and Kim
jong-un and the like take a look at this
if a governor issued a state home when
you say my authority the president's
right mind because it's not me this is
when somebody's the president of the
United States the authority is total and
that's so it's got to be a couple of
excuse me you have a cup you have a
couple of bands of Democrat governors
but they will agree to it they will
agree to her but the authority of the
President of the United States having to
do with the subject we're talking about
his total and then check out CNN's
Katelyn Collins here pressing him about
has any governor said they agree that
this is your call take a look at what
Trump says
when someone is President of the United
States their authority is total that is
not we're going to write up papers on
this it's not going to be necessary
because the governors need us one way or
the other because ultimately it comes
with the federal government
that being said we're getting along very
well with the governor's and I feel very
certain that there won't be a problem
[Music]
he clearly had enough of Katelyn Collins
and these are good questions does any
governor agree with you on this idea who
gave you the idea that it is your
absolute authority so this is the way it
works in a dictatorship it's not
supposed to work this way in the United
States now I can assure you if Trump
says let it rip on May 1st or even let
it rip on May 15th many governors are
not going to say let it rip California's
Gavin Newsom is not going to say
everybody get back out there sports the
entire thing Trump can't force Boston
restaurants to open in fact I don't even
know that our governor can force Boston
restaurants to open how do you force a
private business to open right Trump
can't force kids in San Francisco to go
back to school it's patently absurd but
the really scary part is the
authoritarian nature with which Trump
claims he can control every governor and
every state and every business it's not
even clear governor's have some of the
powers Donald Trump is claiming he has
and states that are already a sort of
taking taking and following what Donald
Trump is suggesting he's going to do
have already said we're not listening to
Trump we're listening to our health
experts we're listening to doctors not
the president now this wasn't all Donald
Trump also turned the White House
coronavirus press briefing into a
campaign propaganda event Trump actually
stepped aside at one point and played on
televisions video of governor's saying
nice things about
- I guess prove what a great job he's
been doing this is just a few seconds of
it I won't play at all mercy shipped
down here in Los Angeles that was
directly because he sent it down here
two thousand medical units came to the
state of California these FMS these
these field medical stations and that's
been very very helpful the president has
been outstanding through all this the
vice president's been outstanding
members of the corona virus task force
very responsive we get asked if we could
have New Jersey could have access to a
piece of the beds that are on the US and
as comfort and the president came back
called the a shortened few minutes
before I walked in here to say indeed
they would grant that to New Jersey so
that's a big step for us in addition to
all the other capacity this was
essentially a campaign video and
reporters realized this might in a way
violate campaign finance rules asking
Donald Trump was that video produced
here at the White House by
administration staff it was done in my
government employees by people here at
the White House this campaign style took
some clips and they just ran him for you
and then lastly the briefing started
with Anthony foutch he having to get up
there holding his hat proverbially and
saying despite all of the reports that I
said Trump could have saved lives by
closing and acting earlier everything
was done when I asked everything is
found fine pouchy was then asked the
donald trump tell you to say this and
here's how fout she reacted everything I
do is voluntarily please don't even
imply that now to me it seems like a
very reasonable question - Anthony foul
gee and voluntary can simply mean Trump
lost his you-know-what behind the scenes
and foul she volunteered to make a
statement in strict terms Trump might
not have told voci you've got to make a
statement today but Trump can still flip
out and make it clear foul he needs to
do something it struck me as one of
those hostage proof-of-life type videos
they're treating me well and I'm being
fed
really the stuff of nightmares and now I
want to dig into one of the specific
elements of that propaganda video that
Donald Trump played today's program was
made possible in part by better help.com
slash Pakman better help is an online
service that gives you access to your
own experienced fully licensed therapist
via phone video and text when you see a
therapist in person in their office it
can take three weeks on average before
you're able to get in for your first
appointment but with better help you're
matched with a therapist who fits your
needs within just 24 hours and you get
the same professional service and the
best part is that better help is less
expensive than seeing a therapist in
person as well plus you will have
totally unlimited access to the
therapist you can talk to them whenever
you want on your phone or computer and
because better health believes in what
they do they also have a full money-back
guarantee if you're not happy with the
service you'll get a full refund no
questions asked
all of their therapists go through an
extensive vetting process and are
required to have at least three years of
experience before joining better help so
you know you're getting someone who's
fully qualified to help you but if you
don't think that your therapist is a
good fit better help lets you switch to
someone new at anytime if you've been
thinking about getting involved with
therapy you should really check out
better help just click the link
underneath this video